[Music]
what up guys I'm psyched we finally have
access to chapter 95 of attack on Titan
and it's definitely one of the most
revealing chapters yet there's literally
so much to talk about like the nine
Titan the truth about rider's father two
of the mysteries I was insanely curious
about if you guys haven't already be
sure to subscribe because we have plenty
of attack on Titan videos on the channel
already and many more on the way now if
you're psyched already go smash that
like button and let's jump right into
the chapter review the manga chapter
starts with Reiner and Gaby and finally
we get a scene where Gaby finally calls
out Reiner for acting different I was
really wondering about when that would
happen I mean this is his family after
all
again we see just how much Gaby cares
about Reiner Gaby speaks about Reiner
living through her through the inherited
memories of the armored Titan which is a
really interesting concept that I look
forward to seeing Mora the first King
has seemingly lived on in this way
through the Reese family until Grisha
finally took the power of the founding
Titan from them but he always had the
potential to come back we see that
Gaby's dream of inheriting the armored
Titan is also tied to her love for her
cousin Reiner which is why she gets so
passionate about inheriting the power
it's a way for her to stay close to him
even after he dies then we see Falco who
was pumped up as ever to surpass Gabby
inherit the armored Titan and save her
from the curse of yamir however as much
as I'm enjoying the information we're
getting about how things are for aliens
in Marlay I do miss her main characters
and I'm really hoping that we see them
soon how do you guys feel about this let
me know gabby and taco butt heads both
passionately wanting the armored Titan
power we just talked about one of the
reasons why Gabby wants it but it also
goes beyond that Falco more
realistically wants to save Gabby from
it while Gabby idealistically believes
that by working with the government of
Marly she can actually save the LD ins
her character and her naive trust in the
Marlin government is definitely
reminiscent of Reiner and the way he was
idealistic and blindly believed that he
could save Aldean's by killing bad
ldiots
the island then we get an interesting
scene of the current generation of
Marlin warrior shifters having tea it's
nice to have tea sometime so Zeek I
guess he means when you're not killing
scores of people and turning them into
Titan it's nice to have some relaxing
tea time but on a serious note these
chapters have been trying to humanize
these characters so let me know if it's
working for you guys have you guys
started to empathize with these
characters or used to like no way no
enemy of Mika sucking ever get my
sympathy baka these instances are what
the YouTube comments section are all
about so guys let me know anyways
Zeke points out there is a problem since
the marlane people have crushed
resistance using the power of the Titans
the world hate the L Dean's who can
become Titans more than they ever did so
the solution that Zeke was a genius and
tied with hundred four smartest
characters in the manga comes up with is
they have to devote themselves to Marlay
which is funny because it is exactly
that kind of thinking that got them to
this point I really do think that Z
cannot be this completely brainwashed I
said it before he has to be planning
something but the question is what then
afterwards the marlane commander Magath
who is eavesdropping on their private
conversation with the other higher-ups
mentioned that if Zeke hadn't said some
unnecessary things they left a trail off
probably meaning that if she hasn't said
some unnecessary things that maybe
Galliard might not have questioned the
plan which is interesting again another
small but meaningful clue that something
is off about Zeke with his 11 out of 10
score in intelligence we can assume that
you wouldn't say unnecessary things by
accident I believe that everything he
does is intentional but that's beside
the point right now the big news in this
conversation was the reveal about the
nine Titan Power Zeke says that the turn
the world's opinion around about the LD
ins they need a narrator they will have
to make clear the threat posed by
Paradise Island and then supposedly deal
with the threat meaning that the world
will come to see these aliens who
brutally put down all of their
resistance as heroes kind of a naive
train of thought but anyways that is
what
because saying publicly while being
monitored by the higher-ups but the
interesting thing is that you will have
the tiber family if I'm saying that
correctly assume this role now here's
where things get real crazy apparently
the family controls the power of the
warhammer tightened the ninth and final
typing power if you guys remember before
the great titan war aside from the
founding titan which went to the royal
family the other a titan powers went to
the other important families which
always fought and in this way pretty
much allowed marley to come to power the
Tiber family apparently was the first to
betray the Eldeen King inside with the
revolution now unlike other LD ends they
live in mansions and are very well off
they adopted a non-interventionist
policy in both politics and war which
explains why they never aided the marlon
army they also appeared to have a lot of
influence which is interesting
so does those prove that the attack
titan was one of mar lays 7 titan powers
before it was stolen by the owl because
they never had access to the Warhammer
Titan Porco Galliard sees a problem
since the Tiber family despite having
the power of the Titan has not fulfilled
their duty to protect the country so
they shouldn't act like heroes all of a
sudden when the LD ends were suffering
in internment zones all this time now we
don't actually see the Titan and
apparently they haven't really used it
as Galliard points out so the question
will remain do they really have it or
are they bluffing that they still have
it to preserve their lifestyle influence
because we know that rod Reese also
successfully pretended that the fighting
Titan was still in his possession to
protect himself so it still is possible
at the Titan power might actually be
with someone on the island of parodies
until we actually see it and not just
get hearsay evidence regarding it I'm
really curious about how it's going to
look since you don't really see Titans
with weapons like a Warhammer usually
except in ancient drawings so I'm
wondering what it will look like let me
know what you guys think the appearance
of this 9 Titan would look like in the
comments section below this family
promised in front of everyone to gain
control of parodies in one year but will
they actually use the power of the
Warhammer Titan or just leave it to the
Marlin warriors to do
that remains to be seen then after that
mind-blowing revelation we get another
flashback of Ryder's life we see Annie
and the female Titan and even Marcel as
the JA Titan who again looks
significantly different from you mirrors
draw Titan form and noticeably different
from Porco's form we don't necessarily
get any new information about the Titan
powers as we already knew the jaw Titan
is smaller than the other two but it's
also the most agile and is referred to
as an assault Titan which is pretty cool
the beast Titan is said to be as always
somewhat bigger than the others and it
mentions its pitching skills that can be
extremely powerful long-distance weapons
again Issei Yama reminds us of Zeke's
secret power the miracle the child of
wonder which likely refers to his
ability to turn and control Titan of
course people cannot figure out why he's
so special and I believe that even
though Zeek knows it is because of his
royal blood he purposely is withholding
the information from the Marlon
government I think if a yama is
regularly reminding us to be on the
lookout for Zeke's possible secret plans
and we even see peek in the cart man or
mule Titan and although a lot of you
think this is like the worst Titan ever
and would never want to get stuck with
it and I agree the military does point
out it's exceptional endurance and its
versatility when it comes to using
different equipment but you have to hand
it to the mule Titan P can stay in that
form for months even if carrying cargo
is not the most glamorous of jobs that
being said I do like to character peak
and I look forward to seeing more of her
in the future
it is also cool how they call the
colossal Titan the god of destruction I
never thought of that
or phrasing like that but it makes
perfect sense as a name and goes really
well with the colossal Titan power then
commander Magots colleague says that
people of the world will probably come
to sympathize with the Devils on the
island because they will to be attacked
by this god of destruction which is a
great point then we see maggots make the
point that it is madness for the
military to entrust the retaking of the
founding Titan to four children while
his friend points out that they just
crushed an entire country here we see
that maggot does see the LDN war
as children and more importantly humans
while most of the others like his
colleague see them only for their
destructive potential and only really as
monsters then we get a huge reveal as
the warrior children get ready to go to
paradise Reiner sees his dad he
confronts him in the barracks where his
mother worked before she got pregnant he
seems to be an ordinary low-class Marlon
worker finally riders dream after all of
his hard work is about to come true
he has worked so hard to become a
warrior and get honorary marlane status
so that his mom and dad and him can live
together as one big happy family
he idealistic we thought that his father
would no longer have to feel ashamed of
him and his mother but he's wrong
his Marlon father makes it clear how it
was all always a pipe dream he says that
if anyone finds out he was the father of
an LD and his whole family would be
finished he would be beheaded
he said he'd run from Reiner the child
of the LD and devil he says that to his
own son and this way he proves what was
sort of pretty obvious already at the
honorary title is a farce
even with all this hard work and
sacrifice most people including his own
father will still see Reiner as a devil
as a monster then we jump to an image of
his mother seeing him off
she says that his father would certainly
pray for Reiner success and we get one
of the saddest moments in the manga for
me knowing that his father hates him and
doesn't care about him at all and
probably wants him dead
Reiner says yeah agreeing with his
mother not wanting to upset her he
continues playing the role of the
perfect idealistic son which he knows
his mother wants him to be people grown
adults are cheering them on wanting
these child soldiers to kill the island
Devils so that their lives might improve
not that it wasn't clear already but man
this is one messed-up world nevertheless
Reiner takes on his role with renewed
vigor he says he will save everyone from
The Devil's on the island and become a
hero of this world so naive but you have
to empathize with Reiner
as hopefulness despite all the sorrow
and unfairness in the world Reiner is
the only one smiling and waving back to
the people and to his mother the only
one playing the role of the willing hero
while Berthold Annie and Marcel all
frown then we see the young shifters on
the island of parodies they passed the
outer seawall of the island and are told
to capture the founding Titan and we
actually see a young vessel talking
about the founding titan power and how
the king of the walls won't use it even
if they break down the walls really the
whole premise toward them being there is
a farce there is no real threat while
Reiner despite being rejected by his
Marlon father and having his hopes crush
tells him to believe in Marley's
research and Marcel agrees with Reiner
since there is no turning back it seems
like everyone is hesitant about killing
the demons inside the walls except
Reiner who is shocked by everyone's lack
of result then we finally figured out
why Reiner actually got chosen over
Porco Galliard it was because Marcel
intervened so that the army would have a
higher opinion of Reiner in a lower
opinion of his brother and Marcel admits
that he wanted to protect his brother
similar to how Reiner and Falco are now
trying to protect Gaby Reiner is shocked
he can't believe that he was entrusted
with the power because of his own hard
work and merit but because of Marcel he
also doesn't understand why Marcel's
apologizing since inheriting the Titan
is supposed to be the greatest honor
even though it's clear that the others
don't see it that way now we cannot
underestimate the mental destruction
that's going on in Ryder's head right
now after he got rejected by his father
he put all of his remaining dreams and
hopes into being a successful warrior
even if his father didn't want him the
Marlon government saw his worth and
blessed him with the power of the Titans
the greatest glory however now his
friends are not acting like it's a
blessing but a curse and it seems like
he was only chosen not because of his
hard work and merits but because of the
fact that Marcel sabotage his own
brother I mean when you think about
everything that happened in this chapter
alone you can totally see how Reiner
developed a split personality disorder
you can totally see how he had to
suppress these memories he had to betray
his friends from the hundred fourth
Training Corps who accepted him as their
own for the sake of a society that
utterly rejected and hated him then as
if things couldn't get worse we see
yamir's Titan jump up behind him and
Marcel one of Ryder's few friends pushes
him out of the way and is devoured by
Ymir's Titan Reiner runs away and thinks
that he'll save everyone and be a hero
the closing caption says that the boy
who lost everything runs towards
destruction and I really don't think
that there's a better way to word what
just happened to Reiner in this chapter
all of his hopes and dreams have been
utterly smashed and yet he can't accept
that so he continues to believe that he
can save everyone and be a hero
he continues to hold on to that warped
view of reality even as he sees it
crumbling down all around him and there
we have it guys chapter 95 of attack on
Titan and my thoughts about it one of
you guys said that attack on Titan was
the saddest story in the comments and
this chapter definitely supports that
point unbelievable
we did get big info about the ninth
Titan but to be honest that news did not
have as big of an impact on me as did
Reiner story tell me what you guys think
about this chapter in the comments what
do you think of Reiner has your
perception of him changed at all what do
you think of the warhammer titan as
usual i can't wait to see what happens
next
ECM is definitely the king of suspense
alright that's it for today's video
thanks so much for watching guys if you
liked it be sure to smash that like
button and subscribe for more attack on
titan videos and until next time see you
space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]